and then I was up in Canada in Calgary
let me tell you this if you ever been
happy if you haven't been a Calgary I'm
thinking like Calgary what is it you
know I didn't even I don't even know
Canada was a real place for a long time
I thought it was just a you know a place
where America practice safety you know
and practice safety equipment who do you
think about Canada you think well what
is it you know what is Canada it's
America's hat you know it says it's this
cold hat that America wears if you look
at a map and it's like this big cold hat
and and I'll tell you this there's
people up there there's people up there
and they're as friendly I don't feel any
stress when I'm in candy you get there
you don't feel like nobody's
judgmentally looking around there's so
much less judgement like people keep to
themselves but not in a way where
they're doing it to keep away from you
like in America there's this weird and
maybe I feel it more in Los Angeles and
I and that's definitely so like you go
into some smaller towns and there's some
real communities here in this fine
country and you you don't feel it as
much but but in Los Angeles you feel
everybody you know looking over like oh
who's this my life hey you know who's it
who's this oh look at that big Daniel
you know what is you know full body cast
you know or who's this [ __ ] over here
you know wearing electricity around her
neck with him Louis Vuitton's or
whatever you know who's this oh this
kid's got you know this you know this
kids a gender-neutral seabass and he
thinks he's a [ __ ] because he's got a
fan out of it coming out of his back and
you know for different types of
genitalia between his legs oh you know
people think that they're fancy out here
but you don't feel that in Canada in
Canada everybody's just Canadian you
know some people may have a little more
than others here and there but you know
in the end and everybody it seems like
everybody kind of has each other's back
and now look I've spent I've been in
maybe five cities in Canada
broke Canada you could lay down in the
street middle of the street in a city in
a city in a downtown fall asleep and
when you woke up in the morning someone
would have put a blanket on you and cars
that were driving on the street would
have probably shut would have probably
shut their engines off when they got
close to you gotten out of the car and
pushed their car past you as to not wake
you up like that's the kind of people
are just way considerate of others and
it's not like they're trying to be it's
just it's in their nature it kind of
reminds me if I had to guess what
America was like maybe you know fifty
years ago and maybe not for everybody
you know I mean it but you know it'd
probably be I mean Canada's very white
so probably would have you know what
America was like for most people I mean
I know there was a lot of racial tension
and struggle but for regular white
people I bet it was similar it's
probably something that can it is
Canada's the diverse two men they have I
mean it's it's pretty white but
everybody's I'm gonna have a lot of Indy
and a lot of Pakistani I mean it's I
don't know I had a blast man up in
Calgary I didn't know this about Calgary
either it's like the second richest city
in the world because of oil they got
that drip drip they got that drip drop
at a drop
you know damn boy that oil that oil wow
you know it's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one